Americans are marking this week's 50th
anniversary of the death of Robert F
Kennedy the senator and presidential
candidate was assassinated minutes after
winning California's 1968 Democratic
primary his son Robert Kennedy jr.
visited his father's grave site
yesterday in Arlington National Cemetery
it's close to the grave of his brother
President John F Kennedy the younger
Kennedy then spoke with Michelle Miller
about his father's legacy Michelle good
morning good morning we met an RFK
Memorial Stadium in Washington named for
the former attorney general just over
seven months after his death when
Kennedy was killed in June of 1968 the
United States was fiercely divided many
look to him to help heal that divide and
that's part of an unfulfilled legacy
that Robert Kennedy jr. describes in his
new book American values I think my
father would be disappointed oh well
this is happening in the political
landscape it's not a country that ain't
strong words from Robert Kennedy jr.
whose family's legacy has been indelibly
marked on American politics he said
America is an exemplary nation that we
should know the difference between
leadership and bullying that we should
try to promote democracy his new memoir
accounts the days known as Camelot when
his family was among the most powerful
in the world and the most tragic my
family had a lot of tragedies but many
American families don't my mother always
says after my dad died everybody takes
their legs and that there's kids and
watts and in Harlem and and beds I I've
lost their parents they don't have the
support system that we had in our family
I don't think a day goes by right I'll
run into somebody and who comes up
doesn't come up to me and say you know
I'm a nurse I went into public service
because of your dad your book is called
American values did you mean for it to
set the record straight oh really you
know one of the reasons I wrote that was
for that I think that 105 Kennedy
children
there are a hundred and five I think a
cape in the summer that you know the
last time we counted that there were
something like a hundred and five and
the majority of them now did not never
experience again a lot but at the same
time it's a history of Kennedy's and
particularly the 40-year tension between
my family and the CIA the kennedy feud
with the CIA was multi-generational the
family patriarch Joseph Kennedy sat on a
commission that called for an end to the
CIA's parliamentary operations and his
sons John and Robert Kennedy both rails
against the CIA's role in Vietnam
actually my father a week before he was
killed that the first thing he was glad
to owe is to remove the cleanses and
make the CIA what it was supposed to be
which was an intelligence gathering
organization it's almost if you have set
up and detailed an enemies list for
those who may have had it in for your
family there was a lot of enemies that
my father made and they weren't all CIA
is that where the seeds of doubt were
planted that perhaps your father wasn't
killed by the person we say he was
killed by I never suspected at any level
that anybody other than Sirhan Sirhan
had killed my father until maybe three
years ago
what changed Paul Schrade Paul Schrade
was a close friend of Robert Kennedy and
was with the candidate the night he was
shot it was schrade who took Sir Hans
first bullet and it is trade who has
insisted for decades that sir Han could
not have acted alone he's now raised
serious questions in Robert Kennedy Jr's
mind as well anybody who is the autopsy
report is it's hard to believe that sir
and I might add that he is all that
and what's always in front of my father
and yet all shots all the fortune I said
hit my father came from behind him that
leads you to conclude what oh I don't
have any conclusion you know I I mean my
and my opinion is really irrelevant
what's important is what the facts
saying what the autopsy says what the
ballistic evidence and what the
eyewitness it is about so you want it
reopened I I've asked a reinvestigation
of that order the Los Angeles Police
Department told us it did not have any
more information to provide at this time
and in a statement to CBS News Sirhan
Sirhan's attorney wrote in part quote we
are gratified that Robert Kennedy Jr who
has been made aware of the evidence
which justifiably aroused our suspicions
agrees that the matter cries out for a
deeper and unbiased investigation and
Kennedy actually met with him last
December in jail so Michelle you have a
personal connection to this your father
was the first physician to treat RFK you
talked to RFK jr. about this I did it
was such a full-circle moment for me
because my dad was a delegate he was a
city councilman in Compton California
was why he was campaigning with Robert
Kennedy and first and foremost though my
dad was a trauma surgeon so to tell him
how deeply sorry he was that he could
not say this father was a real full
circle moment and he thanked me he
thanked me for my dad's service and I
thanked him for for allowing my father
to be a service to him so it was an
emotional moment moments we spent
together Michelle I think of all the
stories we have covered on the show and
the story you did when you revealed that
your father was the surgeon I think is
one of the most meaningful stories we
have ever done on the show it was a
testament to the coalition of people
that that man and that coalition was in
that campaign
there were all kinds of people there
black doctors Asian nurses there were
teachers who were Hispanic and you know
there was so many people farm workers
there from all over the state it was my
husband coins a phrase the gumbo
coalition yeah and I would have to say
he truly truly had cattle a first time
you got to talk to him about that
it was Wow you are a part in extra for
inextricable part of the American
Chronicle Michelle Miller well my dad
was well you are I'm just happy to be
here at CBS used to Chronicle yeah his
part in the monocle and chronicler
Michelle great to see you thanks